i want to look today at some really
great work being done by our friend
jesse dollamore some of you might
remember last summer jesse filled in for
me when i was away and he actually went
down to the supreme court yesterday and
spoke to
a variety of different demonstrators and
activists and protesters and you know
i'm kind of using all these different
terms because there it was a combination
of different types of folks and i want
to look at a couple of conversations he
had the first one starting with an
anti-choice protester
who seemed to have been
um uh hesitant to really identify who he
was with it's a very interesting and
cringe-worthy conversation so let's
start there jesse doing a really good
job and you can check out his youtube
channel uh podcast let's just jump right
into this first interview that he did
these are the types of folks that we are
up against here and understand that they
don't care about double standards they
don't care about hypocrisy they care
about only
the outcomes and they'll justify
anything to get to those outcomes
what's your name colton
what uh what are you doing out here
today
uh i'm gonna be out here uh doing
interviews just like you about this as
soon as my camera guy gets here but uh i
believe that the sanctity of life should
be protected and the supreme court
shouldn't be politicized and the fact
that
this
opinion was released
the leak is the issue not the ruling
i'm okay with the ruling
but the leak
that comes out so early that just shows
how politicized this is did you know
that the the original roe ruling was
also leaked in 1973 which overturned a
few justices opinions
so
there was
it's like jessie's visibly flummoxed
because
the guy doesn't even seem to realize the
double standard well i'm concerned with
the leak well roe v wade in 73 also
leaked right yeah but that overturned
justice's opinions wait but so what huh
if this happens
time after time after time in the adults
of the supreme court in the history of
the supreme court why is this why is it
such an outrage
because they're trying to intimidate the
justices to overturn their opinions
how how does it equate how does it map
onto intimidation of the justice
by the public opinion threatening the
lives last night they were out here
chinning effelito this thing about the
lives of the justices are being
threatened is so absurd supreme court
justices have great security the supreme
court has great security no nobody's
life is in jeopardy here
are you are you witnessing the same
thing i am relative to what is
aggressive
witnessing and empower her prayer
visuals and uh speeches
[Music]
this kid's just very confused it's i
mean
heavyweight has got to go
well
the majority of the people on this side
is pro-choice yes there are some
pro-life people over there who who do
you work for i'm not going to say you're
not going to say okay
so why was it you ditched the uh
the proud boy motif when when i asked
you to ask questions proud boy thank you
yeah you know the hat and the
the whole the whole little thing you got
going on oh the project veritas hat yeah
yeah not not proud fascist enabler no
really
you want to you're
in a agreement with stripping 50 years
of precedent and human
civil rights of women i am agreeing with
uh protecting the life of the unborn
which murdered over 63 million unborn
children
so are you for the child tax credit
i am four are you for the child tax
credit sir this is a completely
different uh are you for increased snap
benefits this is a completely different
argument it's kind of not actually i
mean this is one of the big things
authoritarian clamp down on medical
choices
but then absolutely ignoring what should
be
a responsibility once you force someone
to have a child because if 80 000
people are born into poverty
um
do you how are you going to fund are you
mad the increaser industry that cancer
industry uh the organizations that fight
against cancer are you against them uh
because they don't fight against
diabetes
no they're no they're true
it's cause and effect right but the
thing is fighting cancer doesn't cause
diabetes fighting diabetes doesn't cause
cancer that i'm aware of so
really good job but by jesse here
exposing this guy um and then here's
another one and this is just an example
again of the sort of like people that
are ancillary and attached to this
anti-choice movement
so first this is a guy i'm gonna try to
see what his shirt i want to describe to
you what his shirt actually says because
it's kind of a
fans
are worse than adam jesse's uh hand it
seems to be saying gay bisexual
transgender morals
something than animals the national zoo
it this is this is very weaponized stuff
national zoo
in 1990
[Music]
in 1990 these girls raped the skirt
these girls from school we took nine
girls down to national zoo trying to
find out that they have any homosexual
animals
national zoo said they have more than
400 different species of mammals animals
exotic animals and nationalism but ain't
nothing but homosexuals
[Applause]
i guess this guy is saying there's a
it's a big red flag for him that a zoo
didn't have any gay animals but then he
goes out goes out in the world and
there's gay people this is pretty deep
stuff guys according to the bible
listening women are called swine and the
men are called dogs because they're dog
like men
so you you can take no issue with
wearing hate speech on your shirt or
just about bigotry hatred
[Music]
[Music]
all right so the guy welcoming the label
of a bigot
really great stuff by jesse and he
speaks to a number of different people i
encourage you to check it out but again
it goes back to when we talk about the
big lie trump really won 2020.
you go and you have a conversation with
these people and you realize
these people are gone to quote alex
jones how there's no bringing them back
and then on abortion you go to the
supreme court you talk to some of these
folks and you realize
there's no bringing these people back
at least not in any sensible reasonable
amount of time great job by jesse we're
really up against it here as many of you
know i'm a busy person i don't always
have the exact correct nutritional plan
for my meals every single day and that's
why i also take a multivitamin and a
couple of supplements but doing them all
separately can be a little bit
time-consuming which is why athletic
greens is just fantastic and they're one
of our sponsors i've been using the
athletic greens since last year it just
really simplifies nutrition i just do a
scoop of the ag-1 and i'm getting 75
high quality vitamins and minerals and
my probiotics and it's all from whole
food sources i drink it in the morning i
know i'm good i don't have to be messing
around with different pills and
supplements or whatever or spend time
planning when what time of day do i need
to take each one i just get it all with
one scoop you can put it in a smoothie
you can drink it straight it tastes
great and then i'm just good for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below